the raging flames rose high above the
rooftops of cape town
a plume of billowing smoke visible from
across the city
[Music]
the building on fire part of south
africa's
parliament the blaze was discovered at
around 6 am by security guards early
reports suggested had started in offices
on the third floor of a separate
building before spreading to the
national assembly where the roof has
collapsed i can tell you now that the
entire parliamentary complex is severely
damaged
waterlogged and smoked damaged
so there's going to be damage
extensively the roof above the old uh
assembly chamber
is the old assembly hall is completely
gone the fire is at the moment uh going
in two different sections with the
section in the middle not a place so
they will have to determine how the fire
spread from the one blaze to the second
place because there's two very distinct
areas where the fire is currently
burning
cracks have already been discovered in
some of the walls caused by the intense
heat
this is a very sad day for our democracy
because parliament is the home of our
democracy and parliament is also a
strategic a key point
all matters will be investigated the
police have started to investigate the
forensic department is here public works
is here we all together
60 firefighters have tackled the flames
thankfully no one is thought to have
been injured but immense damage has been
done to a symbol of democracy in the
heart of south africa's legislative
capital
emma birchley sky news